here's Joe Biden in Chicago yesterday
giving us bidenomics
Bridges Etc
but then we felt a third graded 13th
best inner say uh uh um investment and
infrastructure
2 to 13 indicated labor to labor leaders
they must expand their ranks as I said
more women more minorities that's what
you got to do
and guess what
why knowledge is working
it was a lot of that slurs confusion
racism misogyny drivel endless crapola
and then of course the big one yesterday
I referenced it during the show but we
didn't have the video yet Biden is very
confident about what's going on in
Russia Ukraine because Putin has lost
the war and he in Iraq
it's hard to tell but it's clearly
moving the war in Iraq he's losing the
war at home
guys Putin is losing the war in Iraq so
fear not I don't know what sort of
alternative Universe this man is living
in but okay let's run with it and here's
just some general flubs and confusions
and everything else from Joe Biden did
Joy
Putin May Circle Kiev with tanks but
it'll never gain the hearts and souls of
the Iranian people whether or not
they're pulling back from Fallujah and
the yummies from the
you know we're dealing with that for a
couple SEC inflation is a worldwide
problem right now because of a war in
Iraq and the impact on oil and what
Russia is doing
has Vladimir Putin been weakened by
recently best it's hard to tell but it's
clearly moving the war in Iraq he's
building the war at home
trust me we could have given you seven
hours of that but we didn't feel like
rubbing you over the head today anyway
this is breaking news now also from this
morning headline from CNN because I
thought maybe the reasoning for all of
this was that he wasn't getting enough
brain he wasn't getting enough oxygen to
his brain Biden has begun using CPAP
machine for sleep apnea so you know
about this sleep apnea a lot of people
have this you know that you're sleeping
and you're snoring a lot you're not
breathing properly you're waking up all
the time and actually over time that can
start screwing up with your cognition
everything but it's this big machine
that they put on you to basically like
force the oxygen in and help it get out
we have breaking video this is a Reuben
report exclusive we were able to get
video we are the only show that is going
to have this today of Joe Biden
putting on his CPAP machine
[Music]
[Applause]
poor kids are just as bright and just as
tall as white kids
oh man I'm feeling it today
[Music]